[Music]
when it comes to dating loving your
enemy is not so easy a new American
perspective survey by AEI finds that
politics is creeping into our love lives
62% of Americans say it would be
impossible to date someone whose views
that the president did not align with
their own but not all Americans are
equally likely to say Trump as a factor
in their dating decisions almost 80% of
Democratic women say they would be
unwilling to date someone whose view of
Trump contrasted with their own but for
Republican men Trump is much less of an
issue it's not surprising that Trump is
intruded into our dating lives through
social media and non-stop news coverage
Trump has made himself an omnipresent
feature of American public life and
compared to past presidents Trump
inspires very strong feelings on both
sides most Americans have a very
favorable or a very unfavorable opinion
of Trump and yet few Americans believe
that political differences will zoom a
relationship most believe that
disagreements over finances and children
are more pressing concerns for couples
than politics would you date someone who
doesn't share your political views let
us know in our poll also let us know
what other topics you'd like our
scholars to cover in 60 seconds and be
sure to LIKE and subscribe for more
research and videos from AEI